-Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-It's nice to see you
in person, as well.
-Thanks.
-You look great.
-In person, yeah.
-Yeah.
I wanted to ask you,
'cause I know you're into --
very into fantasy football.
-Yeah. Very, very much.
-How are you doing this season?
-I'm winning.
-You are?
-Yeah, I'm in first place.
-Oh, wow.
-First place.
If Cooper Kupp
doesn't go off tonight,
then I'll remain in first place.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-And you play in this league
with your -- with your old pal,
Paul Rudd.
-With Paul.
Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, who is
the Sexiest Man Alive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just think it would be a little
intimidating to play against.
-Yeah.
I mean, you know,
it's a funny year, right?
There was a pandemic.
[ Laughter ]
So...
-So you're saying that
this is not a real --
-Eh, it's like there can be
an asterisk on it.
[ Laughter ]
I think.
Like the steroids era.
You know what I mean?
Like, "Really?"
I mean, I don't know.
Been an off year.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
You think that --
So, this year, you go,
"Eh, sure. Yeah."
-Menschiest guy, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
I would say, but --
-Menschiest.
-Sexiest? You know...
-but I'm glad you're winning.
I love that.
Yeah, you're in the lead.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I haven't seen you since
"Nine Perfect Strangers,"
by the way.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-That was amazing work in that.
-Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And we were talking backstage,
and I was saying,
'cause I've seen you
on Broadway.
I know you were here when you
were in a Scorsese movie.
What do you get recognized
the most for?
-"Everybody Loves Raymond."
[ Laughter ]
You know I'm not on
"Everybody Loves Raymond."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you had nothing to do
with that show.
-No, I had nothing
to do with that show,
but if I could get --
Like, maybe, if this could help
me to have 10 less people
stop me and say,
"We love you on
'Everybody Loves Raymond,'"
that would be great for my life
because I'm not on that show.
-You were never on the show.
-Never been on the show.
I'm a fan.
Don't get me wrong.
-Yeah, but people think
you're Brad Garrett.
-Yeah, they think
I'm Brad Garrett, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All the time.
-I found a picture
after you told me that,
'cause I was like --
Could you make this face?
[ Laughter ]
This a --
Oh, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you can do the voice?
-Yeah.
-All right, let's hear --
You do the voice, and I'll do --
I'll do -- I can do Ray.
-"Ma.
Ma, Raymond -- Ma, tell Raymond
to stop making fun of me."
-"Ma!"
-"Ma, tell Raymond
to stop making fun of me."
-"Ma, Ma! Hey, Mom."
-That's the show, pretty much.
-Yeah, we did it.
We nailed it.
We should take it on the road.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, but it is --
It's interesting.
But it's --
Yeah, I'm always like, you know,
"He's really a lot taller
than I am."
-He really is.
-He's the nicest guy, but, like,
I'm just not him.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, so just to clear it up,
this is not Brad Garrett.
-Yes.
-Okay, there.
Just so everyone knows.
Yeah, no.
You're Bobby Cannavale.
I want to --
But I want to talk about this,
this "Sing 2"
that you're in right now.
But first, are you working
on something now
where you're
a Neil Diamond impersonator?
-I just did a movie in Australia
called "Seriously Red."
It's coming out next year.
And it's --
It's set in the world
of celebrity impersonators.
And I play
a Neil Diamond impersonator
who's managing
a Dolly Parton impersonator,
and it's a pretty fun movie.
-I'm obsessed with this.
This is --
It sounds fantastic.
-And it's perfect for me because
I'm obsessed with Neil Diamond.
I mean, I love Neil Diamond,
and, like, I could sing him
'cause it's
a pretty low voice, and --
-Yeah.
-And so, I got to sing
a few songs in it,
and it's really -- really fun.
-What's your key to doing
a Neil Diamond impression?
-Well, you just got to sing it
with feeling, right?
Because the songs almost
don't make any sense, so...
[ Laughter ]
You know, just --
you just got to
just really feel it.
Like, what the hell
is "Holly Holy"?
[ Laughter ]
"Heartlight"
is all about "E.T.,"
but, you know...
-Yes.
-...it makes you
want to make sweet love,
even though it's about an alien,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
That doesn't exist.
-That was from "E.T.," yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So turn on --
-Yeah, it's like, uh...
♪ Turn on your heartlight ♪
-Wow.
♪ Let it shine
wherever you go ♪
-Wow!
That is a good Neil Diamond.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, and, uh --
-It is about "E.T."
-Just about selling the song.
Nobody sells a song
quite like Neil, you know?
-Neil Diamond.
No, no, no.
-It doesn't matter
what it's about.
-You have a great voice, though.
I was not surprised to hear this
that you were a DJ at one point.
-I was.
On the radio, yeah.
-In college?
When was it?
-No, I was -- I was about 18,
19 years old, and I was --
I just got a job
on a radio station
that was a motivational
radio station, called WNN.
It was --
I guess there was, like,
a minute there where that was --
that was a thing.
And it was -- it was
just motivational speakers,
and it was called
"For Winners Only --
The Winners News Network."
-Wow! WNN.
-Yeah, and I was --
I called myself "Bobby Savage."
I was on from midnight to 6:00.
-Holy moly.
-And -- And I'd be like,
"Hey, it's Bobby Savage on the
Winners News Network.
Here's Leo Buscaglia on the --
on hugs
and why they're important."
You know, things like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, I've never heard of that.
-And I would play, like,
motivational speakers and --
-Winners News Network.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That was a big deal.
-It was a big deal
back in the late '80s.
That was, like, my --
Yeah, that was, like,
my foray into show biz, I guess.
-I can't believe I'm sitting
next to Bobby Savage.
-Yeah, I know.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, it was very cute
before the show.
We can talk about this, but you
were FaceTiming with your --
your kid.
-My kids, yeah.
My boys, yeah.
-And you're --
By the way,
you're great in "Sing 2."
The cast is incredible.
-Thank you.
My sons are very into the --
You know, they're just starting
to understand what I do for a
living, so we -- we went.
We saw it, and they flipped out
for it, of course.
It's a really good movie.
And Rocco's obsessed
with letting people know
that I'm Jimmy Crystal.
He, like, stops people in the --
you know.
You know, there was a tie-in
with Raisin Bran.
You know, I love Raisin Bran,
so I had a box of it,
and they've got my picture
on the back.
Well, the character's picture
And he took it to school,
and he was like,
"This is my dad,
Bobby Cannavale.
This is Bobby Cannavale."
[ Laughter ]
-This is you.
This is you, Jimmy Crystal.
-Yeah, yeah.
-As you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was so cute.
I was talking to him backstage,
your FaceTime with your son.
I go, "Hello."
And he goes,
"He's Jimmy Crystal."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I go, "Yeah, no.
He's Jimmy Crystal."
He's like --
Yeah, how old is he?
-Yeah, he's very into it.
Yeah, he's 5 now.
Yeah.
-So cute. Oh, my God.
-Yeah, he's cute.
The guys are cute.
Not that smart,
but they're cute.
[ Laughter ]
-Boys.
Boys are boys.
-They're just not that smart.
-I got girls. I got girls.
-How about the ridiculous things
that you say?
Like, this --
Literally, yesterday,
I don't know how many times --
I must've said three times,
"Get your shoes off my couch."
[ Laughter ]
And, like, my 4-year-old was
like, "It's not your couch."
And I'm arguing with him.
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "It's mom's couch."
I said,
"That's -- That's my couch."
-Mom's couch."
-I'm getting a really, really --
Like, very red in the face.
And I go in the bathroom,
make believe I'm peeing,
and I'm crying.
-Yeah, of course.
[ Laughter ]
-Can we -- How do we set up --
How do we set up "Sing 2"?
-Basically, I run a casino
that the gang --
You know, Buster Moon
and the gang...
-Yep.
-...have come to try
to get their act in my casino.
I'm like a Steve Wynn
type character.
Like, I own this huge casino,
and it's --
I'm auditioning them.
-Yeah.
-Maybe this is --
Is that the scene?
-Yeah.
And it's Matthew McConaughey.
-And Reese Witherspoon.
-Scarlett Johansson.
Bono.
-Bono is in the cast.
This --
-Yeah.
[ Light applause ]
-That's the --
-The new U2 song.
It's very exciting.
-All right, here we go.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Bobby Cannavale
in "Sing 2."
Take a look.
-So what's the show called?
-What's it called?
Um, Gunter, you, uh --
You want to tell Mr. Crystal
what it's called?
-Uh-huh.
It's called "Out of this World."
-"Out of this World."
-That's right.
Just imagine it.
Ash?
-Uh, yeah, I got it.
[ Guitar strums ]
-A spectacular musical
that takes your audience
out of this world.
-♪ I want to run ♪
-♪ I want to hide ♪
-♪ I want to tear down the walls
that hold me inside ♪
-I love this song.
♪ I want to reach out ♪
♪ And touch the flame ♪
♪ Where the streets
have no name ♪
-Yeah!
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
-Thanks. Thanks.
It's a great film.
-Bobby Cannavale!
"Sing 2" is in theaters
December 22nd.